yes so
so you've lived 33 years with your last
nb and bin laden what has it been
life-wise when you go to school hey noor
bin laden hey
you know there's an element to that when
you have a last name and it's not like a
last name of washington you could be you
know
related to george washington
lineage-wise but if somebody says
washington well they're going to know
there's a lot of washington's kennedy
people automatically go kennedy trump
they're going to go automatically trump
vanderbilt they're going to go
automatically vanderbilt bin laden
they're only going to go one place
what's life like with the last name of
bin laden
the number one thing
to me is that
carrying a name that is so different
to who i am and my values
has definitely had its challenges
throughout my life you know um and
post the tragedy of 9 11 especially
um that being said
you know you
i have perspective with the situation
right and this is something that has
definitely helped me in navigating the
fact that i carry this name is that i
was
always able to put things in perspective
even at the age of 14 when as i said
this
tragedy happened and so many people
suffered um at the hands of these
barbaric attacks but you see you get to
put perspective and
since that day my thoughts and my
feelings have always been with the
victims of
of 9 11 and so yes i do carry a name
and it hasn't been easy in certain
respects
but my thoughts always go to
to those who have greatly suffered i i
can only imagine but
if you don't mind going pre-14 let's go
to the 12 year old 10 year old
11 year old what did you know about your
family from your father's side because
my understanding is your mother who's a
new york times bestseller she wrote a
book in 04
translated in almost 40 different
languages and she's an amazing work and
i think you have two other sisters i
want to say i i want to say it's three
yeah two older sisters and you're the
younger one and you know
uh uh and then your your mother's uh
half swiss
from the father's side and half a
persian from mother's side both your
grand grandmothers i believe are
persian or iranian and then on your
dad's side being the half
older brother of osama bin laden supreme
14
what did you know about your last name
and what did you know from your father's
lineage what did what did your mom tell
you
did you know some other evil stories and
what the plans were
i'd want to kind of go there pre-going
post 9 11.
there are a lot of questions there but
let me start by saying this
um first of all my parents split up i
was eight months old
um there had been some problems in the
marriage
right before i was born and um and
a few months later um after i arrived
the the marriage collapsed so
and thankfully those events happened in
in switzerland so i've actually never
set foot in saudi arabia
[Music]
so i grew up from that moment onwards
with
in an atmosphere of having you know the
parent my parents
divorce in the background and bless my
mother because
despite you know everything that was
going on and sadly
my father created a lot of problems in
the courts for her
and for us it was for the child for us
the children it was very difficult the
different things
he put us through but bless her you know
i
i never grew up with any anger or
resentment
towards him and she always explained to
us you know that
although she had fallen in love with him
she came to understand that
and after analyzing the society in saudi
arabia for six or eight years when she
was living there with him
she came to realize that that was her
choice and she didn't want to impose
this choice on her three girls
and my father was demonstrating at the
time
some um indicate there were some
indications that he was going to be a
much stricter father
with his saudi in his mind girls as
opposed to his foreign wife and
my mother for her it became vital
especially after realizing that although
the society in saudi arabia had
had modern eyes at such a tremendous
rate
you know in the late in the mid late 70s
after the petrol boom she
at the time had the hope that with that
society would modernize as well but her
analysis
led her to realize that it wouldn't be
the case and it became
imperative for her to extricate the
three of us
from growing up with this um
[Music]
culture and in this society and so
growing up i'm sorry i'm coming back but
growing up i grew up with this
understanding of this clash
of um mentalities
and and values right
from the west you know as opposed to the
middle east and more specifically saudi
arabia
and i would you know listen to my
mother's
stories about uh her time in saudi
arabia
my older sisters when they were in
school the things they were teaching
um them in school you know my sister my
eldest sister she came home from
she came home one day from school and
they had at six years old and they had
made her write in her
in her notebook i love palestine i hate
jews and my mother
saw it and she was like i mean there's
no way i want my
my daughters to learn hate you know
and um anyway this is and this story is
um
is uh she discusses it in the book
and what she went and you know she went
to the headmaster and all of that uh
to to to complain and tell tell her that
she absolutely in
no uncertain terms wanted her children
to learn hate
and so i um
i grew up although
although i wasn't in contact with my
father nor the family
i grew up with all these stories that my
mother would tell me and also the fact
that she was
his right arm and all his businesses and
she has an
incredibly unique vantage point from
which she
analyzes society right because
she was a woman and a foreigner who was
privy to all the different conversations
and power plays between the brothers the
princes
the bin laden family at the time being
the most powerful family aside from the
royal family so all the intrigues and
she analyzed the society which is so
closed to foreigners
and obviously women so i grew up in a
household where
she would tell me these stories i've
always been fascinated by history and
politics and so i loved
hearing about this and obviously there
was a direct
emotional link because of
the fact that you know i was born into
this um
into this family and the situation with
my father
[Music]
so
you